this video is brought to you by short
form okay so one question I get asked a
lot is how should I learn AWS Cloud as a
beginner with so many video courses
ebooks and boot camps out there where do
I even start honestly it all depends on
your learning style I found that for me
I learned best through video courses and
Hands-On Labs but you might be someone
who prefers reading through books and
documentation if so this video is for
you because I'm going to be sharing some
of the best books I'd recommend for
learning AWS Cloud these books are
perfect for absolute beginners and if
you'd like a discount to any of them
feel free to use the special links in
the description below to get anywhere
from 10 to 45 off so without further Ado
let's jump straight into it the first
book I'd start off with is called AWS
fundamentals this is a book that teaches
you how to use AWS in the real world
which means it doesn't just cover what's
required to pass an AWS certification
exam instead you'll learn all the basics
of AWS services and how you can get
started with building Real Life
Solutions in the cloud I have it here on
my iPad alongside all the other books so
that whenever I have some free time I
can open it up and start reading what I
love about this AWS fundamentals book is
that it really goes against what a
traditional book would do which is
usually just providing you with pages
and pages of plain text this book
actually incorporates many diagrams and
screenshots so that you can understand
new Concepts more easily I mean how cool
is this a complete one-page summary of
everything you need to know about
dynamodb I really wish I had this book
back then when I was trying to wrap my
head around all the AWS core Services
because it would have saved me so much
time according to the authors this book
is for everyone who wants to learn about
the fundamentals of AWS programming
experience is not required and the book
will cover the core building blocks of
AWS and infrastructure as code and
according to them this AWS fundamentals
book is not for people who are already
proficient with AWS or those who want to
learn Azure or gcp which makes sense
because it's a book designed for
beginners who are interested in learning
AWS Cloud so if you're interested in
getting your own copy of the book I'll
leave a link in the description below
for 20 off the next book I'd recommend
is AWS for non-engineers and it's
exactly what the title says a book for
non-engineers looking to learn AWS many
people I talk to still think you need a
computer science degree to learn AWS
Cloud but this has time and time again
proven to be untrue having a technical
degree is definitely helpful when
learning cloud computing but it's not
really a prerequisite so if you're not
from a technical background and you want
to learn AWS you can use this book as a
guide to help you get started I
purchased a copy for myself and found
the book really easy to follow along it
has seven chapters and provides an
absolute beginner's guide to AWS the
book covers the core AWS services and
explains billing and pricing as well as
the AWS security and compliance Concepts
and then in the last chapter there's
even tips to help you pass through AWS
certification exam if you're interested
in getting your own copy of the book
I'll leave a link in the description
below for 45 off the third resource I'd
recommend is a collection of ebooks
created by tutorials Dojo these books
are specifically designed to help you
pass AWS certification exams and are a
great choice if your goal is to get AWS
certified there's currently seven an AWS
certification books available and you
can see that the books are relatively
affordable as well I actually bought the
AWS Solutions architect professional
book back in 2021 and I remember it was
pretty useful in helping me understand
the more complex Concepts in the AWS
certification exam but since many of you
watching this video are probably new to
AWS let's have a look at their AWS Cloud
practitioner study guide instead from
the table of contents you can see that
the book provides an overview of the AWS
Cloud practitioner exam and what to
expect after that it covers all the
important Concepts and services that may
be needed for the exam everything is
presented really clearly and the book is
packed with diagrams and detailed
explanations so overall I think it's a
great resource if you have an exam
coming up and want to set up notes next
to you that you can refer to and if
you'd like 10 off any of tutorials
dojo's ebooks I'll leave a link in the
description below for a discount moving
on to the next book this is actually one
I created myself well it's more like a
mini guide rather than an actual book
and it's called 100 best chat GPT
prompts to help you learn AWS and get
hired I recently made a video where I
talked about how to learn AWS Cloud fast
using charge ubt where I demonstrated
some cool ways to use strategypt as a
learning tool however this book goes
into a lot more detail and provides 100
prompts you can copy and paste into
charge BT to really accelerate your
journey of learning AWS the prompts are
designed to help you learn AWS services
and solutions in a practical way so that
you don't find yourself memorizing facts
and figures here's an example of a
prompt from the book teach me how to
build an AWS architecture for a simple
web application that uses Amazon ec2
Amazon RDS and Amazon S3 charger BT
would then provide you with the exact
steps you'll need to take to build the
diagram AI is getting really powerful
but without the right prompts you might
not be able to use it to its fullest
potential and so if you're interested in
check out the book I'll leave a link in
the description below for 10 off the
next resource on the list is AWS white
papers these are completely free but
unfortunately many people I talk to
don't know about them AWS white papers
are documents that provide detailed
information around topics related to AWS
they're designed to help people
understand the best practices and design
patterns for AWS services and are a
great way to dive into specific AWS
topics you can see that there's over 270
AWS white papers available anything from
an overview of AWS services to the AWS
War architected framework let's take a
look at this white paper called
introduction to devops on AWS they have
the option to download the white papers
as a PDF so I imported it to my iPad the
white paper provides a pretty
comprehensive overview on topics like
cicd infrastructure as code monitoring
communication and security for example
in the CI CD section they talk about
tools like AWS code deploy code build
and code artifact what I think is cool
about AWS white papers is that first of
all it's created by AWS themselves so
that you'll know the information will be
reliable and second they provide a lot
of links to other resources and websites
for you to refer to which means that if
you ever decide to learn more about a
specific topic that's mentioned you can
just visit the links they provide to
check out these white papers you can
head to the link in the description
below or just Google AWS white papers as
I've mentioned all the white papers are
completely free so I'd recommend using
them as a guide to deepen your knowledge
of AWS now one of the biggest challenges
I faced when learning AWS Cloud was
keeping up the motivation to study
consistently I don't know about you but
in the first few days of learning
something new I'll be really excited and
put in a lot of effort however as time
goes on I will lose that initial
motivation and struggle to stay on track
and so what I realized is that building
technical skills is only one part of the
equation developing the right mindset
and soft skills is just as important
this means building up the right habits
improve your communication skills and
understanding how to think logically and
that's where short form comes in short
form is the best way to learn new ideas
from non-fiction books they provide
amazing guides and summaries to some of
the most popular books out there like
Atomic habits and how to win friends and
influence people I use short form mainly
to look at books focused on Tech
business and productivity and very
recently decided to check out this book
called The Power of Habit it talks about
how new habit bits are formed and how to
break your unhealthy habits to form
better ones you can see that show form
provides a one-page summary to every
book followed by very detailed guides
that come with interactive exercises and
if I ever want to take a break from
Reading from my screen I can just tune
into the audio version one interesting
feature they have is that if you're a
short form subscriber you get to vote on
what future books you'd like to see they
publish book guides and articles every
week so there's always something new to
learn if you're interested in trying out
a short form you can head to
shortform.com forward slash Lucy to get
a five day free trial and if you decide
to purchase an annual subscription show
form will then give you 25 off okay so
this brings us to the end of this video
If you enjoyed it please give this video
a like and let me know in the comments
below what's your favorite way to learn
new technical Concepts alright bye for
now